yes yes I'm listening to and Juna beats
vol 6 Paul Keeley paper jet what it
could saw you know above and beyond made
some really good music and they I think
they still do to a degree but everything
sounds the same now like back in light
2004-2005 2006 someone like they they
had such a really cool like progressive
sound to the whole like and Juna beats
you know progressive house sounding
thing and now is just kind of like now
it's just kind of weird but um we're
doing this in 1080p so let me know how
you guys hey upload my cell 40 let me
know how you guys feel about about like
I'm broadcasting a teeny piece let me
know if you guys are having any problems
or anything like that but um actually I
drank all my coffee I drink my coffee so
so we don't have any coffee for comic
sick happy for our super late one this
is supposed to happen on Sundays but
we're doing it we're doing it today
because I didn't get a chance to do it
on sunday so you know I'm not too
worried about it but anyway I've been
watching what you guys went saying in
the chat my fellow Watchers my watchers
the viewers I've been watching what you
guys have been saying in the chat and it
is that you guys were cracking me up you
guys will have you guys have a lot of
mixed feelings about the batman vs
superman movie and that makes sense to a
degree you know i think that that with
the Batman of the Superman film it
really kind of splits people down the
middle you know there are some people
who are like man this is going to be
solid and there are some people who were
just kind of like I mean it'll be decent
not gonna be anything too outrageous
only been no sales on like I don't even
know if he is if he's here like a salad
chat I don't think he's in the chat and
now he's not in the chat I was gonna say
if he's in the chat like I would
definitely like hit him up but he's not
on the chat right now but um yeah like I
think it has a lot of people split and
it makes sense you know it makes sense
that a lot of people are really really
split about Batman vs Superman you know
do you bleed you will I mean that was a
stupid teacher I was like really come on
like Warner Brothers you guys can do
better than that
but you see your own comment yes you do
yes you do the trolls are going to come
out in full force because of this but
the really cool thing is I've got the
the great banhammer of mounier at my
disposal so I can just like ban them
forever and and we'll see the really
funny thing is on YouTube what you can
do is you can hide people's comments but
they'll never know and so though post
will be like har har troll like I'm so
funny but the jokes on them because no
one will ever see anything they post so
trolling the trolls but um yeah it just
started like we've just kind of ranting
on about like Batman vs Superman and
stuff like that but i think the batman
vs superman is going to be solid i think
it's going to be good it's gonna have a
few problems here and there were swabs
court you're good morning good morning
to you um it's gonna have some Sun you
know weird moments i guess and it's
going to seem a little strange but
overall I think it's gonna be a pretty
good movie you know I don't know if
it'll be a contender like a container
for like the best movie of next year I
mean but I think it'll be pretty good
you know I mean I think it'd be pretty
solid I mean it's going against Captain
America the Winter Soldier so I don't
know I don't know how I feel about that
like I don't think it'll do as good as
captain america the winter soldier but
it'll still do it also do pretty good
nonetheless so um that kind of power
frightens me um can I see God Benny god
Ben he's not here base Benny base vinnie
is not here um get Bruce Banner and the
hammer so so anyway for those of you
guys who were new um this whole comic
shake off e thing is a weekly Q&A it's a
chance for you guys to ask questions
that you guys have about me about comics
about whatever it is that I haven't had
a chance to answer yet on my youtube
channel and and sometimes ideas for
videos come out of come out of comics
and coffee you know so anyway um all
trolls will be crushed by the banhammer
so let's see uh what do I think about a
glimpse that we saw jared leto as a
joker I think it looks good like we
talked about this to accomplish the
coffee yesterday and I think that Jared
Leto's Joker looks cool because he looks
like the sadistic crazy psychopathic
Joker that a lot of people are
interested in but he seems to lack like
the goofy comedic element of the Joker
which could be good or bad it could
disastrous in terms of how fans receive
him or it could be awesome in terms of
what fans like about them so it's really
in truth it's really going to depend on
the viewer I mean they're going to be
just as being people that praise Jared
Leto's Joker is there are going to be
people who were like this versions Joker
sucks it's not a joke or I know so that
Joker sucks you know and that's that's
basically what it comes down to when you
have coming both films you have people
to go in and they're like there is a
version of a joker that I love because
it was over I grew up with and if it's
not that Joker then that Joker is going
to suck and that's that's how they
that's not leave you at I mean it's just
human nature for people to gravitate
towards what they love I mean I'd do
that you know with movies all the time
and so you know it depends on the person
but I'd say go into it with a clear mind
go into it with a open mind you know
acknowledging that this joker is a
totally different version of the Joker
from any of the Joker's you may shame
make sure the same characteristics he
may you know be just as crazy or maybe
just as funny but at the end of the day
Jared Leto's Joker is a totally isolated
you know a different Joker from any of
the Joker's in the comics so far so um
Rob if Quicksilver can run as fast as a
bullet in age of Ultron why does he die
from being shot by a bullet that's a
good question presumably because he
jumped in the way of the bullets in
order to keep them from killing other
people it makes sense to me so that
seems to be the case anyway I could be
wrong I don't really remember that scene
that well to be honest because it is
kind of meshes together with the
zillions of other scenes in the movie
just because there was so much happening
so nonetheless um why can't I see the
video on YouTube I don't know if you're
posting in this side so you could
probably see the video so i don't know
maybe make sure your flash is updated i
have no idea is batman beyond the
definitive future Batman or else world
Batman if you're talking about the
current run of Batman Beyond I'd say is
a separate Batman because you have the
main Batman continuity where Jim Gordon
is playing Batman but Bruce Wayne's
still alive like we know Bruce Wayne
still alive at the end of Batman number
41 i think it was like you had a guy
walking by he was like Bruce Wayne you
know and and that's that's how we know
that Bruce wave still there so now i
would say for right now i don't know if
it's really like an elseworlds Batman so
much as it is just a different Batman
title um I don't know I mean it's it's
difficult to pin it down in continuity
because they haven't crossed the two
over yet it'll
that'll change if you see a story where
you have Jim Gordon just like fly
through the comic you know alongside
Batman Beyond then we'll know where the
continuity stands but right now we don't
know where it stands next to Jim Gordon
Batman so it's really kind of weird
because as far as I understand what I
when I was reading the story when I was
reading the comic it doesn't give you a
time frame in terms of when it relates
to Jim Gordon so you're at work well
watch it while you were work just just
say like I gotta go to the bathroom real
quick and then just be gone for like an
hour so um what do I think about Civil
War number one by Charles Soule uh you
know it's I thought it was kind of
lackluster to be honest I mean it felt
like the what-if story what if Captain
America I cover the what-if the would've
story was what if civil war didn't end
or what if Captain America fought on
like what if the roles were reversed I
came to earth top my head but it feels
like a what if so if it feels it feels
like every other what if story based on
civil war that I've ever read is what it
feels like it doesn't feel new it
doesn't feel like it pops you know it
doesn't feel spectacular it just feels
like a what-if story and I think it's
gonna be one of the problems with civil
war number one I mean I looked the sales
for the monthly comics Civil War number
one didn't perform that well the top
selling stories for civil for secret
wars right now or renew your vows and of
course the main Secret Wars series those
of those are really it like those are
really the tops well let me double check
to make sure I'm pretty sure I'm right
but let me well we're not going to do
that right now because I have the chat
on either but um I'm pretty sure that uh
that's that's the highest selling that's
the highest selling one so far um but
unless you know they're still pretty
good I mean you know the stories are
still pretty awesome so far um Rob you
still working out i'm about to the gym
soon yeah i usually go in the morning i
hit up a friend of mine pierce like i
don't mean to hit him up and he's been
calling me but I've been so busy like
usually by the time I realized he called
like a few hours of past it's late at
night something like that and I'm just
like man I feel like
but um but unless you know he was he was
a guy that I was like you helped me get
back into the gym and I kind of left him
hanging a little bit so I definitely
needed an idea by the way amazon prime
is having prime day so if you guys are
really good deals go to amazon prime
because i think they were selling like
32 inch tvs for like 75 bucks so it's
stupid how good the deals are there
flash sales so they're up for like 15
minute increments so you basically have
to spend all day sitting sitting at
amazon prime to see if you can to see if
we can snag any of those deals there was
a flash trailer that i know of and i
think they officially announced that jay
garrick is going to be in flash season 2
which you know what that means it means
we've got a jay garrick video coming so
yeah I'm I'm kind of I'm really psyched
I'm interested I mean the flash so is
the flash TV shows also right now so I'm
really excited to see where they go with
it but um hey Rob hope you are doing
well I'm a big fan what is your opinion
on Andrew Garfield estefade a man vs.
Tobey Maguire also amazing spiderman vs
sam raimi um I liked like I really liked
Andrew Garfield a lot more than Tobey
Maguire I thought Andrew Garfield was a
great spider man he was a great Peter
Parker he played the character awesome
he had that great bit of like but he
looked the part like he looked the way
you would expect spider-man donut
ultimately it comes down to riding and
that's the problem people say oh my god
like Andrew Garfield was terrible as
spider-man no the writing for Andrew
Garfield was terrible as spider-man like
that was not Andrew Garfield that was a
crappy writing that he got the first one
was good the second one was garbage in
terms of comparison to Sam Raimi's
spider-man leaps and bounds ahead like
leaps and bounds ahead I mean the the
Sam Raimi's spider-man wasn't bad you
know it wasn't terrible it wasn't great
but it wasn't terrible amazing
spider-man 1 was amazing like I really
loved it and so oh wow Jake York and
Wally West's are confirmed what we're
doing videos on both but um no I am I
think that that at the end of the day
Andrew Garfield was a much much better
he was a bit of physical depiction of
Peter Parker he played Peter Parker
better he was a better overall character
than Tobey Maguire that being said Tobey
Maguire was still good I mean it wasn't
terrible as Peter Parker I mean you know
just he didn't look like a he didn't
look like a teenage kid like I wouldn't
look at total McGwire in the spider-man
films and say that
the definitive nerdy kid that's what I
would expect a nerdy kid look like I'm
just like I mean whatever he looks like
he looks like your average guy as
opposed to like you're below average
nerdy guy so um let's see a last man on
earth why why why you know review what
are you talking about Rob do you think
the new season of arrow will be as good
as the seasons before I think so because
now they're officially saying green
arrow as opposed to we'll just Oliver
Queen and the arrow like I think it's
cool they're stepping into the mantle of
green arrow that being said green arrow
is basically Batman so no let's see I
don't often catch the live comics a
coffee normally still sleeping well
justice sucks welcome welcome to comics
a coffee um hey Rob I'm curious to know
what's your ethnic background I will
leave that to you guys to guess like you
guys you guys guess what's my ethnic
background like what do you think it is
so um if Warner Brothers contacted you
with the part of a star sapphire would
you take it yes of course I would star
sapphires or love star sapphires are
life um I see do you think we will see
swampthing on the big screen again I
doubt it I mean I think swamp thing is
he's really cool to comic fans but he
can he's considered hokey I think to
everybody else and but then again I mean
this coming this comic book world is
blowing up on the silver screen like it
now is a great time to be part of the
county book community it is a great time
to be a comic book reader because it's
all blowing up so fast um they might
make a movie about him I mean they may
very well do it so you know what we've
made everything else let's just make a
movie about him and see what happens and
people may or may not like it I mean
he's a recognizable name that is a depth
that he has really going for him that's
a big thing for swamp thing if people
know who's swamp thing is so i would say
that will probably help them out a lot
besides that I don't know your voice is
like an angel my voice is like an angel
well sometimes when I use my my
broadcasting voice it's it's always kind
of weird and more toned
but you know at the end of the day I
think that people people love the more
like dulcet tones of Rob Jefferson
welcome to another episode of K doz
Cato's your number one source for jazz
music fun fact my dad used to be a radio
broadcaster back in the day because he'd
the people people that's where I got my
voice from people were like you have the
best voice for radio and then some
people always told me like you have a
voice for radio you should do radio and
so that's that's one of the factors that
influenced me getting in and doing this
whole this whole YouTube thing but um
did you see any of the DC Comics comic
panels um I watched some of them I
didn't really watch that many of them i
think i saw the ben affleck one I think
ben affleck had one but I don't number
off to help my head I saw some of them
but not not nearly as many most of what
i saw was I saw the the Deadpool one I
saw the x-men apocalypse one I saw a lot
of those on like what was it um clever
clever videos whatever it is whatever
that channel is here on YouTube they had
a lot of that stuff so our superhero
movies over saturating the movie market
I love them but we'll get tired of them
you will get tired of them as long as
they keep making movies about the same
thing but if they make movies about new
things it's not over saturating like
having a million different Batman films
is over saturating like we've had some
like we've had more Batman films over
the last seven years then we've ever had
in the history of movies I mean you had
you have the yeah Batman Returns or I
guess a Batman began so maybe not the
last seven years but maybe the last like
ten years you have that I begins you had
the Dark Knight you have the dark knight
rises now you have Batman vs Superman
and then you're going to have Ben
Affleck's Batman and you're going to
have Batman in the Suicide Squad that
has been featured a zillion times so
that I understand you're getting burned
out on Superman not so much because one
was about me we have superman returns
but we had no movies up until the Man of
Steel for Superman you know I mean
suicide squads that have been featured
before I don't think is going to know
clevvermovies that's what it is thank
you opinion on the Deadpool trailer the
Deadpool trailer looks amazing again we
talked about this during comics to
coffee yesterday the Deadpool trailer
looks absolutely phenomenal like it's
it's it looks like it's probably going
to be i mean i agree with Vinny on this
I think
going to be the best movie of 2016
because it's going to be a rated r
Deadpool film it's a movie with an R
rating that's customized for Deadpool
like in order for Deadpool to be done
right it's going to have to be rated R
and they're doing that and so I think
it's going to be a great I think it's
gonna be a great film um let's see
Deadpool trailer felt like a setup for
x-force I mean the Deadpool trailer felt
like a trailer for Deadpool I don't know
if it's set up anything for x-force but
you know I mean they could I mean you
could easily do X 4 space off Deadpool
but in 20 years when everyone is tired
of superhero movies will we ever see a
huge crossover of Avengers probably I
mean here's the thing there's a lot can
happen over the course of 10 15 years I
mean Xmen apocalypse could be a total
disaster and Fox is like okay fine
here's the rights back Fox could say
we're just not going to make movies
anymore and they end up making movies
based on riotously end up giving the
rights back to to Marvel I mean anything
could happen you know I mean they could
give the Fantastic Four rights back to
Marvel you know all kinds of stuff gonna
happen this is he could be like okay
fine like will pay you in exhort like
will pay you five billion dollars for
the rights to the x-men and a fan has
look for though just they'll give you
know Fox an offer they can't turn down
and Fox will sell the rights any number
of things could happen you know I mean
there's a lot there's a lot that could
take place you know they could come to
an agreement they could work out a deal
and then we see like the Avengers
crossing over with Fox who knows you
know let's see I think suicide squad
will be the best Deadpool trailer wasn't
funny out of the Dead Pool trailer was
hilarious like like it's you know I feel
like people when they were watching the
Deadpool trio some people were just like
like I'm gonna hate this trailer and
then they watched it it's like why would
you go into it hating it like what would
you watch it if you hate it like why
would you want something you don't like
life's life is too short to be miserable
all the time like you got to have fun
you gotta do stuff that you love I mean
it's it's weird which by the way here's
a question that I have for you guys so I
was thinking about this the other day
because I was watching my video on
watching I was watching one of my own
videos i was watching my video on oh it
was the it was Batman vs Superman
and like I was sitting there watching it
now was just like like huh as I was
watching do you guys ever do that do you
guys do that like when you're watching
my videos or like I'm talking and you
guys are just kind of like huh like you
guys do that that's what I want to know
like I'm curious about that because I
was because I do that a lot like when
I'm watching TV shows and stuff like
that when I'm watching things on like
what is it how it's made you know I'm
just kind of like I'm just watching and
it's just like hey that's cool you know
and I really dig that so um am I going
on holidays I mean have whetted Hank Pym
hit is what if we made a video about
that um but am I going on holidays I
mean I'm going to comic-con and
september-october and probably sometime
during the holidays but Oh Jeremy that's
suck so we'll see you later man why is
doomed scared why is doing scared of
read I mean do mascara free richer's
because like because you had a lot too
sometimes all the time um a doom is
scared of Reed Richards because no
matter what happens um read always finds
a way to be doomed like he always wants
see I knew I wasn't the only one who did
that look I knew it wasn't the only one
you know um I knew I wasn't the only one
hashtag huh huh like like like I knew I
wasn't the only one like that's awesome
um but now I think that that it made
sense you know it it makes sense the
dooms afraid of Reed Richards because
every single time that doom comes up
with a plan Reed Richards will always
find a way around it and so like what we
know is that like that doom having all
this power Reed Richards will find a way
to take it I he'll find a way to defeat
dr. doom and that's why he's scared of
him they usually see here's the funny
thing we're think we're gonna make a
video about this discussing like who's
smarter Reed Richards there dr. doom but
um historically it's just based on the
writer you know there are some writers
like I think when John Byrne was writing
writing
it has look for the doom was smarter
than Reed Richards you know and jonathan
hickman's van der jonathan hickman's uh
yeah his future foundation like Reed was
smarter than doom you know it really
just depends on the writer it just goes
back and forth you know there's no
absolute answer to that question you
know it just depends on the
circumstances it depends on what makes
the best story to be quite frank and so
that's that's how you really know you
know who's smarter than who but um do I
think the New Avengers look look a lot
like anime characters post suger wars oh
yeah yeah I'll go with that I'll take
that I'll take that like that that seems
yeah when we Richard Ross is my video
she's just kind of like huh um Rob what
are your thoughts on a moon night movie
I would go see a moon iMovie see here's
a problem though people out there
there's a lot of people out there who
don't know who Mark Spectre is like we
know we love well I guess I assume you
guys left more expect her but a lot of
people are like we really like moon
night the problem is a lot of people
would look at his character and they
would say this is Marvel's version of
Batman which he is I mean ex exactly
what it is he's Marvel's version of
Batman but a lot of people would be like
he's marvelous version like it's just
Marvel trying to camp capitalize on
Batman which 1i the way let them think
that let's make a movie and we'll make a
ton of money off of it like I'm down
with that like I'd be okay with that but
um why do you keep asking me if I will
ever read invincible like why do you
keep at you ask that all the time like
no I haven't read it like why do people
keep asking about invincible now I
haven't read invincible I may or may not
read invincible I have no idea but like
I'm going to add the i'm going to add
that to the black list so anytime
anybody mentions invincible it's
automatically gonna get blacklisted and
people are going to be able to see it
because i'm tired of people ask me
questions about that um let's see marvel
vs DC who would win uh mmm I mean we've
had this discussion before kind of you
know um and cast myself for the MCU will
do that here in a second I think like
before it was Marvel like I was strictly
like i strictly sided with Marvel before
it was just like I love Marvel i'm
strictly starting with Marvel like I
said you know I think Marvel's much
better than DC but in truth you know
I think that it'sit's it depends like
right now I mean I'm reading DC you like
I'm reading you know all the titles that
interests me about DC you um but DC you
is really good I mean it's really really
solid like viddy was talking yesterday
about how he loved red hood narsil and I
was like I mean I haven't really read it
but you know neither character really
interested me enough like I said I don't
read it today and I was like it's good
like it's really entertaining like I
really like it so far it's got action
it's got comedy you like you know
Arsenal's really cool the way that he I
don't ever said I hated invincible I was
tired of people asking me about it um I
think it's really funny the way like he
opens up issue number one I mean it's
solid you know it's really interesting
and so I think that I think it's a good
story I think that with with Marvel and
DC for me it's more difficult now to say
marvel vs DC so much as Marvel and DC
because I'm really starting to like to
like DC a lot more so the thoughts on
Jim Gordon Batman we will I'm gonna make
a video about that so we're going to
have that discussion DC has better
villains I disagree i think Marvel has
better villains DC has a mixed bag i
think when it comes to heroes DC's like
Marvel like Marvel has some has some
good heroes I mean you've got you know
like I mean you got spider-man obviously
and you got the x-men you got really
solid groups fan has it for the Avengers
Captain America Thor the incredible
whole guy man so on and so forth and DC
you got Superman Batman you got the foam
you got the entire lineup of the Justice
League basically I mean I think of DC
villains I think it like Captain
Boomerang you know and like the the
trickster and stuff like that but but
you also have like the Joker you got
Harley Quinn you got you know
enchantress if you're really big on
Wonder Woman you know you got all kinds
of villains out there for DC which are
pretty solid too I mean you know it's
it's it's difficult to decide which
one's better did you hear the voice of
the thing it's normal just like normal I
mean that's fine ok with that I'm not
gonna like throw my hands up in the air
and be like Travis tree this is a
travesty not only gets that big a video
so
hey Rob Xmen apocalypse reaction okay
here's the thing about the reaction
videos guys a lot of those reaction
videos are copyrighted and so if I make
a reaction video about those trailers
and I upload them to my YouTube they
could it could give me a copyright
strike three of those on my channel get
shut down so I'm not interested in doing
material that's going to cause copyright
problem that's why you guys don't see
that's why you guys aren't seeing a
reaction video for Batman vs Superman or
the Deadpool trailer when it comes out
or any of that stuff because fox and
warner brothers are really bad about
copyrighting all that stuff flagging all
s of malden care Marvel uploads it they
put it out there and people make
reaction videos on it all the time and
there's no copyright issues but Warner
Brothers and Fox are really bad and so I
don't want to get my channel shut down
and and that's why you guys are seeing
those reaction videos this is the
official announcement of why I don't do
reaction videos I'm going to assume
after this anybody that asked me to do a
reaction video is asking for my channel
to be shut down which is hurtful I don't
know what we would want my channel to be
shut down so anyway um they have failed
this city um I'm just running this
comment to see my name on the screen
well I mean kudos do I think Deadpool
can defeat wolf's rain that is a
timeless question because they have
fought over and over and over and over
again like they have fought so often and
that is one of the big questions is
Deadpool better than Wolverine
deadpool's healing factor is more
enhanced but Wolverine is a far more
Frida's fighter than Deadpool is because
Wolverines been alive longer and he's
had more training and fighting so he's a
much better fighter than Deadpool but
you know yeah and Wolverine can die like
suppose okay back in the day and a lot
of the stuff has been retconned over the
years with no real like definitive you
know I guess product no real definitive
like continuation of it but back in the
day and the 1980s or 90s I can't brought
up my head they have something called
the Xavier protocols and the Xavier
protocols were basically Xavier lineup
on how to kill like the x-men how to
kill mutants like the most powerful
characters out there like wool ranging
gray Cyclops how to defeat those
characters or kill them if need be
I think that what he had stated was the
only way to kill Wolverine is to cut his
head off and then keep his head
separated from his body the only way to
keep him dead of course we know now his
entire body being covered an adamantium
as a good way to kill into or to just
take away his healing factor but um you
know we we know that that's the butt but
nonetheless you know Deadpool as far as
we know can't die I mean he was cursed
with life it's a campy thing it's a joke
you know but it is in continuity so um
how do I feel about starwood and Kitty
Pryde it's okay stronger and kriti pride
is all right it wasn't enough like I'm
not a huge fan of it um I could see
where people would like it because it's
a really weird like it's strange Belfast
range bedfellows having all bedfellows
it's a strange mix up having Kitty Pryde
and and star-lord together but it makes
for an interesting story it's just it's
not for me so I never really got it
never really got too into it um do i
watch Game of Thrones yes i watch Game
of Thrones what character do you like
Batman or Superman or both I like both
characters I like Superman because he
represents the greatness of humanity he
represents what humanity could aspire to
you and that i represents a guy who's
just super smart like a guy that you
know that a human that a normal human
can do fantastic things if he has the
intelligence like it has an IQ that
exceeds albert einstein and if he has
billions of dollars at his disposal then
yes he can do incredible things if not
well then you're probably just gonna be
able to do anything special so let's see
we have a hey Rob I'm almost done making
the video where I quoted you it'll be
out soon cool I'm down good to see that
make sure you send me a link on on
Twitter or something like that why is
your e-cigarette so big that's what she
said because this is a cig le 100 plus
and this thing cranks a lot of power it
actually holds two batteries and I mmm
it is good
are salacious this juice is so good he
answered my question oh my god well of
course it's a Q&A session I'm not going
to host a Q&A session they refuse to
answer any of your questions answer my
own questions that are you weird I'd be
a terrible Q&A session while I do a
video on the Inhumans I would accept
that I already have so it would make any
sense to do a second video on the
Inhumans what flavor are you vaping I am
vaping your corner laser quest this
month wish you luck if you're going to
raiding your Beach best of luck because
those guys are amazing um let's see um I
forgot where you asked before see this
is why you this is what happens when you
have a DD like your brain just bounces
around everywhere um where did doom get
the sun in battle world that the Sun is
Johnny Storm he made Johnny Storm the
Sun so he exists out there in the world
lighting it where's the question has to
be asked did everything just exist in
total darkness before like how did that
work why is Jim Gordon Batman we will
discuss that in our video about Jim
Gordon Batman what is the meaning of
life ought to be awesome I love
questions like I love when people ask
questions like that what is the meaning
of life the meaning of life is to be
nice to people do good things and make
the world a better place if at all
possible you know to enjoy yourself to
enjoy life to have fun you know that's
one of the big problems I think that too
many people in this world exists and not
enough people live I heard that quote
somewhere I can't underwear but that's
that's a problem I think a lot of people
have like you're born in the world they
go to elementary school they go to
middle school to go to high school they
graduate they go to college they have a
wife they have kids they have a house
they work they retired and they pass
away and they spend their life existing
and they never spend their life living
and that is a sad thing to see um let's
see is do Marvel's greatest enemy yes
because doom is always pulling the
strings let's see favorite hero Robert
Reynolds the century like he is
fantastic like I love his character
before they did a lot yeah 40 to life
the universe and everything equals 42
yes Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
a I've read the books I've seen the
movie laughs let's see thoughts on arrow
season 4 and flash season 2 which one do
you like more I am looking forward more
to flash season 2 than I am arrow
because what do you think about it flash
has come a long way over the course of
the first season it felt like multiple
seasons to be honest it felt like two or
three seasons but when you look back and
you say that was all season one like
that was huge like that was a huge
season there was a lot that went down
and it was done so well so I'm really
psyched about it thoughts on ant-man I
have not seen ant-man yet and I am
ignoring all information about it so um
let's see thoughts on Tilda Swinton as
the ancient one has she officially been
cast if she has I'm psyched I think
should be nothing should be pretty cool
um I think it's a good idea to take a
break away from tradition and the cast
like a woman to play on deploying the
ancient one why is water giving me the
burbs and because i'm drinking so much
of it I think it's a cool cool break
away from tradition either way Tilda
Swinton never disappoints I've never
seen Tilda Swinton in a role that I
didn't like so I'm pretty psyched about
it um let's see yes multiverse in flash
hold it for me I'm really really psyched
world record hope vs broly brawley any
day of the week like hands down would
obliterate world breaker Hulk no
questions asked let's see what's your
advice on how to start reading comics
well I in depends on what you want to do
so here's a really cool thing with if
you what you want to do is you want to
get in a DC do your backstory like do
some online reading watch my videos
watch many videos or sales videos on the
new 52 and then just start with DC you
which is basically everything that was
released on jun 3rd following that if
you want to get in a Marvel read New
Avengers and Avengers by Jonathan
Hickman which is New Avengers vol 3 and
Avengers vol 5 and then just jump into
Secret Wars that's what i would suggest
that's that's pretty much all you really
need to do anything besides that you can
get a trade if you want to read one more
days you can buy a trade for that which
collects all the comics from one more
day if you want to read any of the old
hoax stories like that I mean that's a
really cool thing now with
secret wars is what Marvel's basically
saying is that all the all the stories
you want to read before sugar Wars just
by the trades you know those aren't in
continuity anymore because a lot of
those characters just don't are dead
like they're not there anymore mamas
really slim down line instead of saying
like oh my god there's like there's like
a thousand characters in Marvel I don't
know where to start cuz it's also crazy
you know you can just be like well
there's like ten characters now and so I
can pick which ones I want to read you
know and go from there you know if
you're reading secret wars and you're
like the maestro like who's the maestro
you can discovery future imperfect which
is a to issue run or I guess yeah to
issue run from greg pak no not great
pack um how do go future imperfect i
don't when brought up by a jeph loeb i
think um but you can go back and read
those you know and that's a really cool
thing now is everything in secret wars
are basically stories based on trades
you know they're old stories future
imperfect planet hulk world war hulk you
know all that kind of stuff those are
all trades so you can definitely go back
and read those rob your favorite cosmic
entity my favorite cosmic entity is
probably huh no um probably Galactus
because he has the most character of all
the cosmic entities which sounds weird I
know because all he does is goanna
consume planets but he's more involved
in the lives of everybody I mean the
cosmic entities as you normally think of
them like you know oblivion I guess
entropy eternity no oblivion whatever it
is the counterpart to what we have in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe eternity
death infinity all that kind of stuff
like they are all just kind of there and
you only see them doing like major
crossover events that endanger the
entire you know all of reality you know
that's that's kind of the weird thing
but um you know Galactus has more of a
presence and so I'm really kind of
really kind of interested about that
Peter David there we go thank you thank
you obviously any was really like jeph
loeb maybe Peter dated or like nuts
rosinski he didn't he wouldn't write
that a future imperfect written by Peter
David yeah do you think spider-man will
have a big impact on the MCU definitely
spider-man is going to have a huge
impact on the on the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
um green arrow versus Hawkeye see so you
guys ask really difficult stuff you like
you guys are like oh hey guys here's a
question let's take these characters
that are perfectly even and are not in
the same universe and say which one's
better like it's you can't I mean
there's no answer to that question you
know um Rob answer my question who will
play Red Hood answer Michael okay you
could say please see I don't do very
well with being given orders on like
being told to do stuff like Rob do this
like that that doesn't usually work out
well so um let's see please answer my
questions there we go hey Rob which
Abdullah I'm Abdullah from Saudi Arabia
I live in the u.s. big fan what's your
character from Harry Potter and which
books do you like most Voldemort hands
down because he was so
characteristically evil he was so cool
such a good bad guy although i will say
that that Delores Umbridge is probably
the most evil person in the series um
he's definitely the really cool
character that being said book for is my
favorite book because it's just so much
stuff happens it's so fun and so it's a
fun book to read and I'm all about
having fun so um let's see uh gets
banned what not banning anybody let's
see what do you read all the comics buy
them on buy them online thanks yes i
have Marvel unlimited so all the old
stories feature imperfect all that kind
of stuff planet hulk world war hulk and
civil war and all I kind of stuff I read
those I'm Marvel unlimited anything else
is playing new i buy like I need to go
to the store or go to the comic book
store later today and by might range for
all the stuff coming out today so have
you ever watched a cartoon series based
on avatar the last airbender no i
haven't i've never watched avatar the
last airbender did I like daredevil why
do you guys asked me to answer your
questions like like hey Rob like here's
a question please answer it like I
answer the questions they come in like
I'm doing my best but you know I mean I
can't can't answer everybody's that
being said daredevil on Netflix it is
good like I dig it
it's it's a really cool show I haven't
watched it a second time there's really
no need to but it's pretty solid it's a
really good down to earth you know
gritty video or I guess movie TV series
like I really enjoyed um if you command
Robbie get bad no you won't get banned
let's see but that film's central guy
for spamming that guy will get the end
like spamming in the chat will get you
banned it'll get you banned forever oh
my god there's once I put somebody on
the banned list I never go back and I
never take them off so you just gone
forever um let's see will Dormammu ever
appear in the MCU and what will it take
to beat him well see that's a good
question Dormammu is a stupidly powerful
villain from from dr. Strange's
continuity Doctor Strange himself has
explicitly stated if Dormammu ever
showed up in the earth-616 continuity in
the main well I guess in the main model
continuity and he he had full power like
no one will be able to stop him so I'd
say that if he showed up he would
probably lay waste to all and I don't
really know of anyone who would be able
to stop him but I'm sure dr. strange
would find a way so uh let's see and
civil war are you team Iron Man or team
captain america I'm team Iron Man which
is a very unpopular opinion it's popular
opinion I think to be on the side of
Captain America but in MSC that's a
funny thing like like when you when you
ask a person you know why like when you
read civil war whose side were you on
like nine times out of ten they'll say
well all's on the side of Captain
America and if you ask why they'll say
well because freedom and that's their
that's their answer there's no real
thought process he goes into it they
just like because freedom is good you
know but it's not it's not freedom
versus security there's a lot more to it
than that it's very complicated let's
see hey Rob love your channel do you
think the Doom Patrol wouldn't make a
good team make a good show or a movie
why or why not um I think would make a
decent TV show definitely not a movie of
movies too big of a gamble TV show might
be even let it be might be even a bigger
gamble but Doom Patrol is not selling
very well so I don't see them doing that
you know and this here's the thing you
guys got to consider when it comes to
making TV shows movies things like that
it makes sense to do something obscure
and
order to gain some fanfare but at the
end of the day they're going to go with
what's popular because that's what's
going to draw people in the exception
here are like suicide squad and
guardians of the galaxy and those were
huge Gamble's but in a normal
circumstances that's why you see so many
spider-man x-men fantastic for Superman
movies it's because they're big names so
are you excited for ant-man yes i am
very psyched for an man i am very much
looking forward to it um let's see Rob
which do you like better Quicksilver an
age of Ultron or cooked silver in days
of future past it's yes that's weird you
know days of future past Quicksilver
seemed faster in age of Ultron he seemed
slow if that makes any sense he didn't
seem as fast um you know it's it's I
mean some people will say that in Days
of Future past he was too fast but i
think it was nothing it was the right
speed um that being said i like the one
in days of future past better to be
honest because he seemed more quick
silvery and that he was kind of goofy he
was immature you know but he was still
pretty powerful so um let's see will
there ever be a martian manhunter movie
i don't know i think it'd be cool to see
but i don't know i'm on the fence about
it you know i don't know i'm not sure i
would go see a martian manhunter movie
to be honest I think Martian Manhunter
is a good character to make a movie
about with him being in the background
like a Justice League film or something
like that as opposed to a movie starring
in so Rob what's your take on the
Suicide Squad trailer I am very height
about the Suicide Squad trailer I think
it's going to be great I think the
movies going to be really good um you
know I think the trailers are really
give anything away to be honest it gives
us the premise of the film but it
doesn't really reveal like anybody dying
it doesn't reveal you know what
direction the Suicide Squad will go in
in terms of will they stay together will
they break up you know how is the house
where we going to end I mean I think I
did a pretty good job you know let's see
Aunt May and spoiler Scott Lang his Ant
Man oh my god you just ruined a movie
banhammer why would you do that um let's
see do I think they should put daredevil
in civil war yes definitely they won't
but I think they should
let's see Rob fan from Wow from gianna I
guess South America did you follow the
twitter reaction to Batman vs Superman
trailer do you agree with let's scroll
back up do you agree with the Batman
with with the notion of Batman is a
highly overrated superhero no I don't
think Batman's overrated I think Batman
is a product of his fanfare people love
Batman because he's a normal guy who can
do crazy things because he's super rich
and he's super intelligent um none think
I don't think he's overrated I mean I
think he's you know he's he has really
good stories you know if his stories
were garbage then I would say yeah he's
overrated but his stories on garbage you
know under scott snyder his stories are
amazing so I love your channel so much
thank you um let's see if you had to be
a superhero what would your powers be my
powers would be to predict the future I
think you know to like not in the sense
that I would be that I would like to be
able to like stop and be like I'm what's
going to happen tomorrow and then
instantly know but in the sense that Lou
be a challenge to it like I would dream
the future I would be clairvoyant I
don't have to decipher those dreams to
figure out you know what the feature is
going to be that I think would be a cool
power either that or I would have the
same power as like sage and that my mom
would be like a computer I remember
everything that I've ever encountered be
able to categorize things perfectly and
recall everything I've ever learned so
that would be a cool concept let's see
Rob do you think mother will try to have
the venom the Venom symbiote venom story
with spider-man if they do it won't be
for a while you know I think this look
this is going to be a basic spider-man
film this is going to be the back to
basics you know Peter Parker gaining his
powers kind of thing that being said I
have no villain no idea which villain
are going to choose I think Mysterio
would be a really good villain because
it's a film that we've never seen in any
of the spider-man films you we've heard
neither hide nor hair of Mysterio
anywhere in any of the spider-man films
and so you know I think it'd be cool to
have them in there um but you know
there's other characters I could
definitely go with I mean Eddie Brock
venant would be a good
and you know but they've done venom and
I think I think Marvel's trying to steer
away from what Sony's done so far so you
know I think you know some of the ones
that we haven't seen yet I mean we've
seen the lizard we've seen Sandman we've
seen venom we've never seen carnage um
you know I think it'd be too early to do
carnage you know we've seen Doctor
Octopus we basically seen everybody but
Mysterio so I think Mysterio will be a
really good choice let's see my wife
remembers everything I have ever screwed
up she has that superb remember that one
time let's see ant-man hopefully will be
a hit I think it will I think man is
going to I think a man's gonna sneak
into the theaters and blow up like I
think that's what's gonna happen nothing
people are gonna be like yeah let's just
go see a man and see what happens I
gonna walk out and be like that movie
was amazing I'm not sure either way I'm
really psyched like I'm definitely gonna
go see it is Xavier a bad teacher and a
bit of a jerk I wouldn't say he's a bad
teacher but he is like he's an [ __ ]
like Xavier is a terrible person let's
see Rob actual doom or Thanos Infinity
Gauntlet um you talk about doom from
like the from singer wars because
they've stated in secret wars that this
version of Thanos from 616 from that
that universe is destroyed is more
powerful than all the other verses of
fan owes on in the and circuit board
right now so that fan of us which by the
way he was awesome like he was so cool
and in secret wars number four like that
was that was like V Thanos where he was
like it was like if one were truly God
the one would not shy away from it you
know but you know I think that that that
version of phantoms with the Infinity
Gauntlet would stomp the [ __ ] out of
doom because doom is even though he's
smart this power is new to him and
that's what a lot of people don't get
like a lot people don't understand that
even though doom has all this power he
has the ability to do virtually anything
he's so new to all of this like he
doesn't he doesn't nobody's doing
basically you know and that's that's the
cool thing you know that's the
interesting thing you know having said
that I think that I don't know i mean i
think that with with Thanos to the
Infinity Gauntlet he's had power
absolute power so
times he had the infiniti call me yeah
the Cosmic Cube he had the heart of the
universe you know he's had he's had all
these different forms of power and he
knows how to use them intelligently and
so I think that he would be I think he
would usually stop the crap out of doom
because he's just more experienced let's
see uh thoughts on Superman red Sun one
of the best stories of all time and I'm
actually doing a script on it it's
difficult to do the script because the
story so big but yeah I'm we're here on
the script forward see Rob what are your
thoughts on Robbie Reyes as the all new
Ghost Rider I haven't read it yet I
haven't read a ghost rider title in
forever so I'm not really sure how I
feel about it um let's see is dark
phoenix the most powerful Marvel
character not by a long shot but she is
really powerful she's she's very very
powerful she's right up there but there
are characters far more powerful than
her Franklin Richards dwarfs the power
of the Phoenix force and you've got the
high level cosmic entities you know
eternity and infinity and so on and so
forth you know the thing about about
Phoenix force is that the Phoenix force
can't necessarily be destroyed because
even if a Phoenix force were obliterated
entirely it will return like it always
finds a way to come back because that's
the nature of the Phoenix force so a
customer won't get you the banhammer a
customer will automatically get
blacklisted so nobody will see your
comment because I'm trying to keep like
this is a family-friendly channel and
we're keeping it clean so so yeah it is
like your comment just won't show up um
let's see thoughts on Geoff Johns
helping a flick right the Batman solo
film that is amazing news I hadn't heard
that but that is really good news
because it means it'll be rooting it
written adequately like it means it'll
be written well because you've got one
of the best Batman writers you know for
a long time helping him write the story
so let's see how to do get his powers in
secret wars we don't know I'm all we
know is that dr. doom Doctor Strange and
and molecule man killed the beyonders
and took their power we don't know how
they did it we just know they did so
is the new suicide comic any good it's
okay I've read a little bit of it I'm
actually was that I'm on suicide squad
number nine now I think like the new
Suicide Squad because here's here's the
thing you had the new 52 Suicide Squad
and then they rebooted the Suicide Squad
yet again and call it new Suicide Squad
so there's so this is the second version
of The Suicide Squad in the new 52 um
it's not selling very well and I'm not
the biggest fan of it that being said
it's a cool premise the problem is no
one knows how to write the story well
like no one has no one knows how to
write good stories for for like suicide
squad no one knows how to write those
well you know that is that's that's the
problem um all right that guy is getting
blocked um let's see if DC and o hara
I'm Bob if you see a model did a
crossover should low key in the dark
knight joker team up and Rec everyone uh
that'd be entertaining like it'd be fun
but no I don't think that's gonna happen
like I don't think that would that what
happened if it would be pissed um let's
see is dr. strange really dead we don't
know we assume so we believe he is but
we don't know so let's see Suicide Squad
is more interesting how can they be
friends like what I don't know what that
means let's see what's the next video
you were going to upload I'm working on
a script today for Secret Wars 1984 so
that's probably gonna be the next video
that I do scouts the matter should help
in a fly guess he should because he's
been doing amazing work with Batman but
you know I think that he's basically
been on Batman I mean he's so Scott
Snyder as far as i know is writing
Batman and I think he's doing detective
comics i'm not sure but he's been
writing so much for Batman I don't even
know if he has time to branch off or
anything
who killed a living tribunal when Iron
Man and The Watchmen and the watcher
fine and we talked about that during one
of doing our incursions video but the
beyonders killed the killer living
tribunal let's see when does Secret Wars
5 cut out i don't know i think it comes
out next month but i'm not sure you know
I'm not a little number off the top my
head let's see Rob who could defeat God
doom I think the Reed Richards will be
the one to beat him like I think Reed
Richards will just find a way to take
its power or to just defeat him outright
but I'm not sure well Cyclops rise from
the ashes or is he truly dead well
remember the Phoenix force is just a
vector like where I guess some persons
just a vector the Phoenix force is a
totally separate entity if Cyclops's
physical bodies dead I mean he's a
Phoenix force he could probably just
resurrect himself but you know I'm not
sure I mean at this point is it's
jonathan hickman so anything could
happen and jonathan hickman could write
anything he wants to right now I mean
what he's doing right now with the
Secret Wars where the secret war story
is going to set the stage for the future
of the model universe and so you know
him you know with Scott Summers being
dead I think the question is will
somebody else become the Phoenix force
in which case it'll most likely be Jean
Grey from one of the other realities but
you know we're not really sure yet what
do you think will be the greatest fight
in the Marvel Universe that hasn't been
done oh that's a big question I I can't
answer that right now um I guess to take
a crack at it I don't know I mean I have
no idea could you explain hope summers I
mean I guess I could but I don't really
think she's relevant right now so let's
see hey Rob what do you think of expert
apocalypse I think Xmen apocalypse is
going to be solid I think it's gonna be
a really really really good movie at
least I'm really looking forward to it
anyway um let's see Rob please answer
you too man morning should DC do an
Origin solo movie for Batman earlier
than he confirmed Batman solo movie no
they need to let umm Danah let Ben
Affleck run with his batman film because
ben affleck's good at directing and he's
he's decent at writing I mean him
and him and Matt Damon had shared credit
on Good Will Hunting even though we all
know that Matt Damon wrote that will be
by himself but um I think I think I'll
do a good job with the new Batman so I
think he wants to do it justice and I
think that he's I think they'll do a
solid job with it how much money would
you bring to comic-con and depends on
what you want to do because it can be
very expensive like for those two
pictures that I got a comic con that
costs a lot of money so why is one above
all not in secret wars we don't know the
one above all probably has no concern
about what's going on he may just kind
of be like it's the natural order of
things or the one above all could be
dead and like I have no idea maybe the
Hickman just doesn't care about the one
above all and will never include his
character in there I have no idea so um
let's see thoughts on the Marvel summer
event thing well what we've been talking
about that already um see what's under
the Alice quarterly I was good yes they
were very very good stories they're
probably set on the bed really they were
probably some of the best stories ever
buy Batman since arkham knight or not
working right since nightfall to be
quite frank um playstation or xbox
playstation playstation has better
exclusive games xbox has better
multiplayer games let's see do i play
hearthstone no I don't play hearthstone
let's see kids Superman died yeah super
Megan died he's been killed before he
was killed by doomsday he presumably
being almost powerless right now can die
who would win spider-man spider-man or
iron man um well they fought several
times the past they fought during civil
war they fought after Civil War it
usually comes down to a standstill I'd
say it's yeah it's usually did I'd say
it's about even spider-man has has a lot
of strength but I America compensate for
that with virtually any of the armors
that he has so it really kind of depends
anyway guys um this has been real this
has been fun we're going to go ahead and
call it um I love answering these
questions with you guys but I need to
get to work on the script and I need to
the finish reading my get my trades or I
guess my comics for today but thanks for
coming out guys
I'm sorry to get a chance on Sunday but
we'll be back on Sunday for the right
time or for them I dated you are
comically coffee I'll comics a coffee
thing but anyway I'm going to get a
bounce off here and then we'll catch you
guys later peace